>>> IN "EYE ON EARTH," OUR
PLANET IN PERIL, CBS NEWS WILL
BRING A FULL WEEK OF COVERAGE TO
MAKE THE 51st ANNUAL CELEBRATION
OF EARTH DAY NEXT THURSDAY.
CORRESPONDENTS AROUND THE GLOBE
WILL LOOK AT HOW CLIMATE CHANGE
IS AFFECTING EARTH AND EXAMINE
CREATIVE EFFORT TO HEAL THE
PLANET.
HERE'S A LOOK AT JUST SOME OF
THAT COVERAGE.
♪
>> Reporter: I'M MARK PHILLIPS
OUT HERE IN THE ENGLISH CHANNEL.
A LOT OF HISTORY HAS BEEN MADE
HERE.
ICE AGES, INVASIONS, BUT NONE OF
THAT COMPARES TO WHAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS DOING TO THESE WATERS,
TO THE OCEANS OF THE WORD, AND
TO US.
>> THIS IS ABOUT 30 ACRES OF
PLASTIC WASTE.
THE COUNTRY'S CHOKING IN IT.
I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT ONE YOUNG
WOMAN WHO'S TURNED THIS MOUNTAIN
OF DESPAIR INTO ONE OF HOPE.
>> I'M TONY DOKOUPIL IN NEW YORK
HARBOR WHERE RESEARCHERS ARE
LEARNING HOW TOXINS ON LAND AND
WHAT WE FLUSH COULD END UP HERE
IN OUR NATION'S WATERWAYS.
WE'LL SHOW YOU WHAT'S BEING DONE
TO CLEAN UP THIS PRECIOUS
RESOURCE.
>> Reporter: THESE FIVE WIND
TURBINES PROVIDE ALMOST ALL OF
THE OFFSHORE WIND POWER IN THE
UNITED STATES BUT THAT'S ABOUT
TO CHANGE BIG TIME.
>> IT IS COOL TO SEE IT UP
CLOSE.
>> Reporter: I'M BEN TRACY OFF
THE COAST OF RHODE ISLAND.
WE'LL SHOW PLANS TO INSTALL
ENOUGH OF THESE TO PROVIDE POWER
FOR MORE THAN TEN MILLION HOMES.
>> Reporter: HOW ARE THESE
LITTLE GUYS PART OF THE PLAN TO
TACKLE DISCRIMINATION, CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND INSPIRE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF BLACK FARMERS?
THAT'S A LOT.
I'M MICHELLE MILLER IN
SLOANSVILLE, NEW YORK.
THAT STORY COMING UP ON "CBS
THIS MORNING."
>> AND ALL THAT SPECIAL COVERAGE
AND MORE, "EYE ON EARTH: OUR
PLANET IN PERIL" KICKS OFF
MONDAY ON "CBS THIS MORNING."
AND CBS NEWS WILL BRING YOU A
SERIES OF REPORTS ON CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STORIES ACROSS
EVERY BROADCAST AND PLATFORM ALL
NEXT WEEK LEADING UP TO EARTH
DAY.
>> YOU ARE VERY BUSY.
YOU'RE IN THE WATER.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO JUST TOOK
THE RED EYE IN FROM CALIFORNIA.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HE STARTED --
>> I NOTICED THAT MARK PHILLIPS
GOT TO GO SAILING.
YOU GOT TO GO WAIST DEEP IN NEW
YORK HARBOR.
>> NEW YORK HARBOR.
NOT AS PICTURESQUE BUT
IMPORTANT.
>> YE